okay thanks for tuning in everybody I
want to talk again about the
never-ending campaign to sexualize our
children and and by the way someone
asked me the other day you know why are
you so obsessed with this issue what why
do you keep talking about it well that
that's true that I am rather distracted
by the fact that our society is
normalizing facilitating encouraging the
sexual abuse of children that is a fact
that I admit I am focused on and so my
question back to anyone who asks that
question of me is why aren't you focused
on it can you can you name let's say ten
issues that are more important okay so
now an article in The Daily wire that's
written by Josh hammer it says on
Facebook Fairfax County Virginia school
board candidate Priscilla desta stuff
DeStefano de Stefano let's call her
let's just call her Priscilla sounded
the alarm on the news that unless
parents opt out children in the county
would be mandated to take the Fairfax
County Youth Survey lest they that
survey sound innocent enough she
highlighted how the questionnaire would
reportedly grill children as young as
eighth grade on whether they are
sexually active whether they have
engaged in oral sex on how many sexual
partners they've had in eighth grade
it would also reportedly probe children
as young as sixth grade about whether
they smoke marijuana or drink alcohol
this is her Facebook post she says
starting this week sixth eighth tenth
and twelfth graders will be given the
youth survey unless you opt them out the
sixth grade survey asks about drug use
like if they've ever huffed aerosols to
get high please look through it to see
if you're comfortable with with your
eleven and a half year old being asked
to 84 questions a survey well then she
noted how the fairfax county survey is
even more intrusive the eighth tenth and
twelfth graders are asked much worse
questions like if they are if they've if
they've ever used heroin or LSD their
prescription drug use and their sexual
activity like if they use condoms
they've had oral sex and how many sexual
partners they had and then Josh hammer
notes that a similar story unfolded last
month and can or
Carolina when I survey given out to
local sixth graders required or inquired
about the students sexual orientation
local ABC affiliate ABC eleven reported
at the time the mother of a Terrell Lane
sixth grader is upset after a survey
given to her son included a question
asking about his sexual orientation 6th
grader why are you asking 11 year olds
these questions asked Connie Joe
Hutchinson the program is called
shifting boundaries which is a very apt
name and quite Orwellian shifting
boundaries which is funded through a
federal grant in the survey hand
understood as the six the sixth question
asks what is your sexual orientation it
then lists ten possible options bisexual
gay fluid heterosexual lesbian pansexual
queer questioning prefer not to disclose
and self-identify so these are 11 year
olds being asked if they are pansexual
okay so there are a couple things
happening here first of all we see again
the normalization of this kind of
activity among kids the thing is when
you even so much as ask a kid have you
done X the implicit message that you're
sending is what you're really saying is
X is an option or people do X or even
you're weird if you haven't done X so
when you go to eighth graders and you
say have you had oral sex you are
essentially suggesting it to them and
that's that's not an accident it's
called normalization it's called you
saying hey people your age do this kind
of thing and that's okay but you know
there's something else here too there's
another message being smuggled in
smuggled in well I don't even know if
you could call it smuggled because it's
so conspicuous and they're barely trying
to hide it but that message is is that
the schools the teachers have a right to
this
kind of information so when a when an
adult asks a question like this to a
child the message to the child is from
the message from the adult is I have a
right to know these things about you and
it is appropriate for you to discuss
them with me and this is literally what
pedophiles do this is how they groom
their victims the point is to break down
boundaries they call the program
shifting boundaries that's yes exactly
and that's what sex offenders do I know
sex predators break down boundaries make
the the victim think that it's safe and
healthy and appropriate to be talking
about these things with this adult and
of course it's not it's not appropriate
among all the other problems with this
stuff is the issue that as an employee
of the school system it's none of your
damned business whether these kids are
sexually active or or what they're doing
is as far as that goes it's just it's
none of your business why would it be
your business why should you be having
this conversation just because the kids
come to you to learn the ABCs and one
two threes why does that automatically
mean that you get to know everything
about them and why do you need to know
everything about them in order to teach
them that information
this effort by the school system to take
the place of the parents to step into
that role and box the parents out well
that's what this is all about and think
about this also and it you know these
are just two examples of this kind of
stuff in the school system but you find
this all across the country
it just it only comes to our attention
when someone complains about it on
Facebook but there are many examples of
this where nobody's complained about it
so we're not we're not talking about it
but think about what what this involves
the school
system wants to know things about your
child that you don't even know
necessarily so that's part of what this
is they're trying to get these really
intimate information and it might be
stuff that you don't even know you
should know as a parent you should be
having those kinds of conversations with
your kid or at least well I wouldn't be
having the conversation in the way the
school system does but yeah if you have
a sixth grader who's who is sexually
active that's something you should know
as a parent but regardless the the
effect here is that they're asking us
questions and they are compiling
information about kids and even if it
shouldn't be that way a lot of this
stuff is stuff that the parents don't
even know so the and and that is part of
the school system taking the place of
the parents now a lot more in this in
this vein to talk about before we
continue though I have a quick word to
pass along from our friends at quip quip
makers of the equip electric toothbrush
wants you to know the one single
discovery that matters most for your
dental care and it's simply this if you
have good habits you're good that's all
it's all about good habits that means
brushing for two minutes twice a day
flossing regularly no matter what brand
you use quip makes that simple starting
with an electric toothbrush refillable
floss and anti cavity toothpaste quips
electric brush has sensitivity sonic
vibrations with a built-in timer and
30-second pulses to get to guide a a
full and even clean the quip floss
dispenser comes with pre-marked string
to help you use just enough plus quip
delivers fresh brush head floss and
toothpaste refills to your door every
three months with free shipping so your
routine is always right and you can
maintain those good habits again that's
what this is about
join the over three million healthy
mouths and get quit today starting at
$25 and if you get clipped calm and if
you go to get quip comm slash Walsh
right now you'll get your first refill
free that's that's your first refill
free I'd get quit calm
/ Walsh spelled GE t qu IP comm / Walsh
quit the good habits company ok now
staying in this in this general realm
this series of videos was brought to my
attention by someone on Twitter goes by
the Twitter handle question LGBT edu so
question LGBT education and this is a
person who's concerned about the
doctrine indoctrination and sexual
ization of kids and they've been sharing
these videos and I talked to this person
to ask where they got the videos from
these are so it's a video from a youtube
series for kids 9 through 12 12 and it's
it's called sex ed school here's the
description if you go to their website
sex ed school says sex ed schools an
entertaining and educational youtube
series about sexuality and healthy
relationships for youths ages 9 to 12
each episode features two expert hosts
Nadine and Eva leading a respectful and
authentic dialogue on sexual health and
guiding participants through fun and
thought-provoking activities about
specific topics knowing about sex is
good but understanding love healthy
relationships and consent is key for
kids as they contemplate their future
it's never been a more important time
for parents and educators to get
comfortable with the uncomfortable and
start talking about sexuality and
healthy relationships with kids now
let's meet the hosts this is how the
these two hosts are described Nadine
Thornhill is one of Canada's foremost
experts on child and adolescent
sexuality for over a decade she has been
helping youth make positive informed
choices about their bodies and
relationships in her spare time Nadine
enjoys escape rooms weekend hikes with
her family and watching bad television
with her fur baby albus dumbledore a
litter he has a master's focusing on the
social psychology of sexuality with
interest in technology she's also the
creator of the inclusive evidence-based
YouTube channel for young adults
what's my body doing she's a winner of a
Planned Parenthood Toronto's Choice
Award 2017 for excellence in sexuality
education IVA can be found dancing her
heart out at Zumba class scooping out
new threads at her local consignment
store or trying out new ways to make
vegan cheese now this is this is real
guys I'm 98% sure this is real even
though if I were to invent someone who
made a you know a person who's making
sex ed videos for kids on YouTube if I
were to invent a fake person it would be
exactly that it would be evil bloom with
the vegan cheese and everything but I
did go to her Twitter and it appears to
be real in fact in fact I saw on her
Twitter in case you're interested that
she's also giving a sexting workshop so
you can you can go to her pay her money
to attend a workshop and find out how to
sext if you're interested in that well
these are the two people making sex at
videos for kids featuring kids and it's
as hideously insane as you're expecting
it to be here's a clip put together by
by that Twitter handle I mentioned and
they added some captions of their own
some critical captions that obviously
aren't part of the original but anyway
here's a here's a clip hi I'm Nadine a
sex educator I use the pronouns she and
her because I'm a woman and when I was
your age I used to be a girl gender is
how you feel on the inside about whether
you're a boy or a girl a man or a woman
if you're not binary feel like neither
or both people can also be fluid feel
more like female like male
honest based on a different day or time
it's really individual absolutely
everyone born with a vulva is a girl too
or false
not everybody is sure and that makes
sense but our genitals actually don't
determine our gender so some people born
with vulva and boys learn a little bit
more about gender we actually have an
extra special visitor to sex ed school I
have been through the spectrum if we
were to say a spectrum of like boys and
girls
I have been everywhere in between I was
born a girl and then when I was 2 years
old
I told my mom for the first time that I
was a boy and I think that I framed it I
don't remember it I've only been told
stories but I framed it because my
brother's middle name was the same as my
dad's and so I insisted that my middle
name was also the same as his but back
in the day there was no talk shows and
there was no internet there was no
resources so she just ignored it and
then nothing happened
for many many years and then it still
took me a long time into my 20s before I
decided to transition
well a few gem gems in there people can
feel more male or female based on the
day or time did you catch that one of
those I think it was Eva Bloom that said
that one of them said it you can whether
or not you're male or female can
actually change with the day or time so
you know maybe you feel more male at one
o'clock in the afternoon on a Thursday
but at 7 o'clock in the evening on a
Sunday you might feel more like a female
of course these kids because they're
kids
don't ask a simple question like well
what does that even mean what do you
mean feel like a male or female and how
do you know that the feelings you're
having are male or female feelings and
to even be speaking about male and
female feelings are you not reinforcing
gender stereotypes I mean if you're
saying that ok if I'm if I if I haven't
be feeling that particularly sensitive
and emotional right now that's a female
feeling that must be what you mean but
doesn't that reinforce all the sexist
gender stereotypes and stuff that you've
been trying to break down now the kids
aren't gonna ask that question the kids
are gonna sit there and they're gonna
listen and they're going to assume that
whatever the adult is telling them is
probably true that's how kids operate
kids kids have to operate that way in
order to survive where it's just it's
hardwired it's built in as children you
just basically believe whatever an adult
tells you
because as a child if you were only
going to follow the instructions that
you understood or if you were going to
require that you fully understand
everything before you go with it then
that's just not going to work because
kids don't have the capability of
understanding even things that make
sense so a child has to some level just
sort of defer to the adults around him
the problem is if the adults around him
are insane that's gonna be a problem and
then the woman at the end there says
that she realized she was a boy at two
two years old - do you have any idea how
young - is two years olds when she came
to this realization now let's continue
this journey with with the woman who
discovered she was a boy at at - watch
this yeah if you are a girl and like
your little how did you like change to
become like a boy so in my 20s for my
personal journey I started with hormones
which is what changed my voice a bit and
it changes your body a little bit yeah
yeah so that is because I'm on
testosterone so like do you have male or
female parts I'm sure a lot of people
ask where a lot of people are wondering
that for me personally I have had Top
surgery which means that I had the
technical term as a double mastectomy so
I did have my breasts removed so I have
scars here on my chest and then I really
only talked about kind of what's in my
pants if people are getting in there
we're gonna play a game involving some
chairs how these chairs that you
selected oh yeah you look very
comfortable how are you down there
maybe that chair doesn't feel like it
suits you right why don't we switch
chairs
let's see everybody's gonna stand up
you're gonna do a little walk gonna walk
it out I'm Addie I'll ring the bell walk
it out walk it out oh my lord so we are
we are now comparing biological sex to a
game of musical chairs and choosing a
sex is like choosing which is the most
comfortable chair
that's the illustration we're being
given here that you're your physical
body is no more significant than a chair
and in fact is just as arbitrary as the
chair you happen to be sitting on and
then changing your body is as simple as
just getting up and sitting in a new
chair leaving out all the stuff about
how you're mutilating you're getting
expensive surgery permanently mutilating
your body I mean the thing about sitting
down in a chair is that yeah you can
just you're gonna get you're sitting in
the chair for a second you can get up
and sit in a new chair but if the chair
is being surgically attached to you
that's a different story right and
that's what's being left out here so if
this if this game was to be at all
accurate than the the chairs would have
to be surgically attached to you and
then it's not quite so easy to pick a
new chair but of course the entire
analogy doesn't work at all because your
body is nothing like a chair that's just
that's just not how it works and this is
what this is one of the many things that
it is impossible to understand about
this way of thinking because most of the
people who subscribe to this and would
say so
thing like well maybe you have the wrong
body or your body doesn't work for you
most people will say that are you no
they're not they're not like devout
Christians religious people most of them
are going to be basically secular
materialist the point there is that from
that perspective in that worldview all
you have is you you are your body you're
not anything but your body that's all
you are so when you talk about you and
you when I if I were to say me the only
thing I am referring to is just my body
so for me to say that my body is the
wrong body doesn't make any sense
what I'm what I'm what I am then saying
is I am the wrong me this me is the
wrong me I should be a different what
that's nonsensical the only way you can
begin to make sense of this is if you
introduce a concept like a soul and then
you could try to say well I've got a you
know I'm a female soul stuck in a male
body the problem there is that first of
all you're coming up with a relationship
between body and soul where the body is
just in fact you heard it there is just
a vessel that contains your soul which
is not how it works but also okay you've
introduced soul now you've introduced
God okay and so now you're saying what
God accidentally put the wrong soul in
the wrong body he made a mistake on the
assembly line so what's unit once you
introduce soul it still doesn't make any
sense because now you're suggesting that
God made a mistake in how he matched up
the soul and body and the only way to
fix it is to mutilate your body all
right
as we continue let me pause for a moment
to tell you about Brickhouse nutrition
have you ever wondered why so many
Americans are sick unhealthy overweight
between the food supply in a sedentary
lifestyle Americans are in the worst
shape that they've ever been and that's
why the team of on staff physicians at
brickHouse nutrition created field of
greens field of greens is an easy way
for you to add fruits and vegetables to
your daily routine without spending
hours in the produce section or higher
a home chef or taking you know cheap
supplements none of that forget about
all that field of greens is made with
real USDA organic fruits and vegetables
it also helps boost your immunity and
using antioxidants and and it assists
your digestive health with prebiotics
and probiotics so it's like having a
doctor and a nutritionist right there in
your kitchen one scoop delivers a full
serving of fruits and vegetables just
drop in a cup of water
you know stir it and and that's it
you're done it's also great for
smoothies as well that's how I prefer to
have it with a smoothie bottom line this
is real food not extracts and you will
look and feel better go to brick house
Walsh calm and get 15% off your first
order just for trying it out with the
promo code Walsh that's brick house
Walsh com promo code Walsh okay so
speaking of nutrition there has been an
outcry recently over people allegedly
getting arrested for eating sandwiches
on public transportation maybe you've
heard about this let me see if I can
pull this up reading now from Mercury
News says a top BART official apologized
on Monday after a Bay Area man was
arrested for eating a sandwich on the
platform last week capping a viral
incident that angered riders and spurred
and eaten on Saturday in a statement at
transit agencies general manager Bob
Powers apologized directly to the rider
identified by key T V you
KTVU as Steve foster of Concord and said
he was disappointed in how the situation
unfolded Powers said enforcement of
infractions such as eating and drinking
inside our paid area should not be used
to prevent us from delivering on our
mission to provide safe reliable and
clean transportation I apologized to mr.
Foster our readers our riders employees
and the public who have had emotional
have had an emotional reaction to the
video so people have had an emotional
reaction I apologize to the people who
have been emotional about it
videos of the November 4th encounter
have racked up more than a million views
on Facebook and Twitter since they were
posted on Friday Bart said foster was
stopped for eating in the system which
is against state law and that Foster was
handcuffed when he refused to provide
his name for the citation foster also
allegedly cursed at and made homophobic
slurs at the officer power said but the
incidents spawned outrage among Bay Area
Transit riders many of whom saw it as
racially motivated and a case of an
overzealous officer enforcing a
little-known rule Foster's black--the
officer arrested him as whites
so on and so forth okay I'm going to
part company with I guess most people on
this everybody seems to be mad at the
cop I think that's totally absurd and I
think for mr. powers here the the
general manager of Translation general
measure for him just to throw you know a
BART police officer under the bus like
that or under the Train I guess as it
would happen is completely outrageous I
mean he's a Polly's exist enforcement of
infractions such as eating and drinking
inside our pate area should not be used
to prevent us from delivering on our
mission to provide safe and clean
transportation isn't isn't the idea of
enforcing the ban on eating isn't isn't
that in order so that transportation
will be clean isn't that the whole point
so what powers are saying is that the
enforcement of the rule against eating
has interfered with their mission of
making everything clean what how I think
it's all completely ridiculous and by
the way the man was was not arrested for
eating a sandwich and that's that's how
it's phrased in the very first sentence
of this article arrested for eating
sandwich no they tried to give him a
citation for eating a sandwich but he
refused to cooperate so they arrested
him now my question is what else are
they supposed to do if they try to cite
you and you refuse to accept the
citation or to give your name are they
supposed to just throw up their hands
and say okay nevermind sorry to bother
you if you get pulled over for speeding
and the cop asks for your license and
registration
should it be an option to just say no
I'm not giving it to you and then and
then if you say that should the cop just
leave
can I really do that if a cop asks my
license can I say nope not gonna give it
to you no and then and then the cop
walks would simply walks away Oh turns
out he doesn't want to give his license
ya know he doesn't to give his license
ya know he doesn't want oh oh you you're
saying you don't want a ticket is that
what you're saying yeah yeah I'd prefer
not to have a ticket oh then nevermind
be on your way be on your way I thought
maybe you wanted one but if you don't
want one that never mind
is that how law enforcement is gonna
work no if you're going if you're going
to do law enforcement that way where the
the law with where the law breaker has
the ultimate say in whether he'll
cooperate with enforcement if that's the
way it's gonna work you may as well not
even have law enforcement officers
anymore and you may as well not even
have the law anymore because it's
effectively moot now you might argue
that this is a dumb law that it's a dumb
nanny state law and and and that this is
not how you know law enforcement should
not be focused on this kind of thing
that's a fine argument I'm not
necessarily a disagreeing with it I
don't necessarily agree with it either
because I actually think that having a
rule against eating on public
transportation I think there's an
argument to be made for that because the
fact is that people are slobs and so if
you let them just eat wherever they want
there you're gonna end up with trash and
food all over the place it's the same
reason when you get into a new borough
or cab usually there's a sign that says
please don't bring food or drinks in
here that's not an issue of law that's
just their own personal rule but why do
they have that rule they know people are
slobs and if you bring in food you're
probably gonna spill it are you gonna
leave the trash and so I don't want to
deal with that so I think that people
are acting like it's crazy to have a
rule against eating on public transition
I don't I don't think it's crazy but all
in all I'd probably agree that this is
not something that the state necessarily
needs to get involved in and we don't
need to have officers focused on this
but the police don't write the laws okay
they aren't the ones you should be
yelling at
law makers make the law that's why we
call them lawmakers police are law
enforcers so it's not they don't have
any input whatsoever into the laws
themselves and it's also not up to them
to decide which laws they prefer and
then only enforce those we don't want
them to do that
no they just enforce the law if you
don't like the law itself go talk to the
nanny state politicians who put it in
place this police officer is a transit
cop his whole job is to enforce laws on
public transportation that's what he
does that's his entire job and provided
that the laws are not flagrantly immoral
okay if there was a law that said that
that that like everyone in a flannel
shirt has to be thrown in front of a
train or something then I would agree
that that's a law that the police
officers would have a moral obligation
not to enforce because I'm just
following orders is not an excuse to do
objectively immoral things a law against
eating a sandwich on the train is not
immoral you could say it's stupid
frivolous it's not immoral another is
there's no moral conflict here and if I
was a police officer and I knew that my
job hinged on enforcing laws like that
I didn't force them I'm not gonna get
fired so that you could eat a sandwich
on the train why should i it's not that
important
so this is this is how you should take
it up with don't like the law take it up
with the people who made the law what I
don't get is that without with every
time it's we're always focused on the
people enforcing the law and the people
who make the law get off the hook in
fact sometimes you you have the law
makers themselves turning around and
criticizing the the law enforcers who
are only enforcing the laws that those
lawmakers made I got pulled over
recently for going 45 and a 30
personally I think it's really dumb
because the section of road that I was
on was there's no reason for it Abby
30 mile per hour speed limit if there
was nose no houses around it wasn't
residential there were no schools it was
just kind of a straight back road chunk
of road there and I didn't see any
reason for it to be 30 miles out I think
the speed limit should have been 45 or
50 but it wasn't it was it was 30 and I
was breaking this peoplein I got pulled
over I didn't get mad at the cop for
pulling me over
why would I it he's he's sitting there
it's his job to enforce the speed limit
I broke the speed limit and so he pulled
me over it's really simple
I didn't start crying about how I'm
being picked on and you let all those
other people's speed but you pulled me
over yeah probably yeah a police officer
can't pull over literally every single
person who speeds but they're gonna get
a few of them and if you might be one of
those people and it might be your
unlucky day to start crying and I can
persecuted about it like this guy is
with the sandwich look it's a you might
not like it that's the law you broke it
it's not like you have some sort of
constitutional right that you're taking
a stand all these people that are doing
to eat in taking a stand for their right
to eat a you don't have a right to eat
on a train someone actually said to me
on a few people on Twitter brought up
said that this is a constitutional issue
and one person even said that when I
said well okay no you don't really have
a constitutional right to eat oh they
someone said well where does it say in
the Constitution that you can't eat on a
train someone actually said that not
joking I don't think they were joking
they were being serious and if you don't
know what the problem is with a claim
like that then I'm not gonna explain it
to you but in any case it's it's it's
not you know this is not an issue of
right served First Amendment or anything
it might be a frivolous frivolous and
stupid law just like the 30 mile per
hour speed limit on the area that either
that that part of the road that I was on
I think that was frivolous and stupid
it's slaw and it was being enforced I'm
not saying that we should just accept
every frivolous and stupid law I don't
think that at all I'm saying we should
take it up with the people who make
those damn laws that's where we should
that's where we should bring our
grievances so if you're gonna have an
Eden or something if it's that important
to you which frankly I don't know why it
is that important of all the things I
think something like the speech I think
frivolous speed limits that are there
only to trick you into speeding so the
state can take money from you
I think that's far more outrageous and
more worthy of our outrage than a rule
against eating on a train but that's
just me any case if it is that important
to you then why aren't you going to the
State Capitol finding where the
lawmakers aren't having your eat in
there so that's what doesn't make sense
I used to live in a beach town and there
were all kinds of dumb laws every beach
town has them have tourists areas all
kinds of dumb laws about what you can
and can't do on the beach for example
you can't drink alcohol the beach I
always think that's pretty stupid
but and there would be cops on the beach
enforcing these laws I didn't get mad at
the cops for enforcing the law they are
cops in a beach town just like this is a
cop a public who works in public
transportation this is what they do they
have no choice but to enforce the laws
in this area that is their job so with
the beach town I got mad at the local
officials who came up with these stupid
rules and that's where the anger should
be directed another dumb thing people do
is when they go they say well why is he
focused on this when he could be out
arresting murderers and rapists oh it's
really that simple huh so a cop could
just hop into his car go downtown and
arrest 16 murderers and 27 rapists
before lunch is that how you think it
works why don't you go arrest some
murderers yeah I'm sure they'd love to
it's not that simple
there's a there's a process you have to
go through he's
Batman you can't just show up and use
his grappling gun leave a guy tied to a
lamppost okay you know there's a to it
to arrest murderers there's
investigation this there's a whole
process that goes into it and it's just
not how policing works now I'm not a
police officer myself I'm not familiar
with all the procedures anyone who is a
police officer maybe you can fill me in
on this but my understanding is that you
know you don't start your day down at
the station and the police chief says
okay go arrest some people and then you
just get in your car and go wherever you
want
and try to arrest murderers my
understanding is that it doesn't work
that way you have certain specific
things that you're supposed to do and
areas that you're patrolling and certain
you know that that's my understanding
so the guy on the train the cop on the
train I'm sure he would love would love
to arrest a murderer if there was one to
arrest but there probably wasn't now if
you have evidence that this police
officer walked right past a guy in the
process of being murdered and didn't say
anything so that he could yell at the
dude with the pastrami sandwich if you
have evidence of that then I will
totally agree that we should be really
mad at this cop in fact cops probably go
to jail for negligence but I don't think
that's the case I think that he was just
there and forcing the law he was a guy
breaking it he didn't arrest them he
didn't he didn't he didn't cuff them at
first all he's just say okay I got to
give you a citation not a big deal okay
without this isn't we're not making a
huge thing of it but you did this I'm
right here watching you do it I'm a
police officer so I'm gonna cite you for
it I don't same with it looks like
anything else it's like it's like
getting mad at the the meter maids that
the people that give you parking tickets
you come out you see someone putting a
parking ticket on your car you start
yelling at them people do that what are
you yelling at them for if you really
think that it shouldn't have to it
shouldn't cost you anything the park and
this
particular area which maybe it shouldn't
depending on the situation then don't
talk why are you talking to them this
this they're just doing their job okay
so I just I'm not going along with that
outrage I'm afraid to say I'll meet you
guys for the next outrage I'll catch up
with you later okay let me know when
there's a better outrage and I'll be
there let's go to emails Matt well show
at gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com
let's see this is from Kimball says hi
Matt you need to read this it is
absolutely outrageous I can't believe
anyone would make such a ridiculous case
to defend the Soviet Union this article
will have all of us get down on our
knees and praise this communists for
their aid in World War two and
conveniently ignore the atrocities of
Stalin's rule you don't need to apply I
just wanted to bring this to your
attention
Campbell Kimball sends a link to an
article in The Daily Beast or the daily
least as I call it no actually I don't
call it that I apologize that's a that's
a boomer move that's the ultimate boomer
move to come up with some corny but
insulting nickname for people and things
you don't like like a Barako Bull is a
member of the demon crap party that
always gets favorable coverage in the
New York slimes and the rest of the
lamestream media anyway so the daily
least article is titled nine reasons to
thank the USSR how we got the Cold War
War wrong nine reasons to thank the USSR
how we got the Cold War wrong so I did
read this after it was sent by Kimble
written by a guy named Brian T Brown who
just wrote a whole book on the Cold War
he's allegedly I guess a historian which
is it's like if someone who pretends to
be a real historian wrote an article
titled actually Hitler is good and and
that comparison is completely fair
because Stalin was just as evil as
Hitler if not more evil and the Soviets
murdered well more people in the end
though that's because they had a lot
more time to do so
so the nine points that he makes about
why we should thank the USSR and why we
got the Cold War wrong and that is his
case remember he's saying that we got
the whole thing wrong and that viewing
ourselves as the good guys is wrong and
and and and so what evidence does he
bring to bear for that first he brings
up the Eastern Front in World War two
all the sacrifices made by Soviet troops
and the fact that so many were killed
many more Soviet soldiers were killed
than were American soldiers and and
that's that's true but nobody is saying
that there was no physical courage among
Soviet soldiers there was obviously
quite a bit of it that's no one is
claiming otherwise it's the USSR it's
that government that regime that didn't
value the lives of its own people and
that just fed them into the meat grinder
with no regard for them and then when
they got home as Solzhenitsyn recounts
and Gulag Archipelago when they got home
many of them were shipped off to labor
camps for the crime of being potentially
exposed to Western culture Stalin was
worried that they got a they got a look
at Western culture maybe if they came in
contact with American troops or
something and now they're gonna see how
cool the West is and they're gonna want
to be Western and so when they came home
he would just ship these guys off to
labor camps for 5 10 15 years so if you
want to point out all of this as
evidence that people living under Soviet
Russia were persecuted and many of them
were good people who didn't deserve that
kind of treatment then yes I would
totally agree but that's not the point
that's not the argument when we talk
about the Soviet Union being evil we're
talking about the regime we're not
talking about all the people many of
whom were being persecuted and oppressed
themselves and then from there he goes
into more about what Soviets did during
World War two and he complains about
McCarthy and he says America did some
bad stuff too and that's the whole case
basically that's that's it amazingly the
word gulag doesn't appear anywhere in
this article he just completely skips
over it leaves it out he's trying to
rehab
Tate Stalin and doesn't even bother to
mention the labor camps where millions
of people were shipped off and tortured
starved beaten raped and killed he just
completely ignores it like it didn't
happen it's it's embarrassing and The
Daily Beast obviously does not value its
credibility at all probably because it
knows it already has none so might as
well just go for broke I suppose okay
this is from Nathan says hey Matt this
is Nathan I'm from Utah my question is
regarding my relationship of two years
with my now fiancé we've had issues for
a while but I'm starting to doubt the
solidity of our relationship and if it's
worth working out I love her but she can
also be controlling and I'm starting to
feel like I have no say in relationship
in and freedom in my relationship I've
tried to bring this up to her but it
always backfires on me and becomes my
fault I don't want to make this seem
like everything in our relationship is
her fault but I've definitely
contributed but I feel like I'm not as
happy as I used to be
we still have amazing times together
just I feel like they may not be enough
I would appreciate your input on what I
should and can do okay now I have to put
on my doctor love hat again it's
invisible it's invisible hat I've been
getting a lot of these a relationship
advice and emails recently and I'm not
exactly sure why the fact that I
convinced a woman to marry me for some
reason somehow I was able to do that
that I don't think it makes me an expert
in relationships in in fact this is the
tough thing it's kind of a catch-22
because if you're successful at romantic
relationships then you probably haven't
had that many of them because if you
found the right one and you stuck with
it and that is what success in romantic
relationships looks like but then but
then the problem is you don't really
have all the experience with varying
types of relationships to dole out
advice however if you have experience
with a bunch of failed relationships
then that means you really suck at
relationships and you especially can't
dole out advice so that's the problem
there and with that caveat I will say
that well I'll say what I often say in
these kinds of situations and I don't
to be too quick and telling people to
pull the plug but my thought is if you
aren't married and you don't have kids
then there's really nothing tying you
together and you could this is someone
who you could have out of your life in
ten minutes if you wanted to now I know
you're in you're engaged so that makes
that makes it a little bit more
complicated I suppose in a certain way
and that's going to make the emotional
difficulty of breaking it off more
severe and then you know you've got all
the people who are looking forward to
wedding and now you got to tell them at
weddings I'm having so those are all
things that are awkward and difficult
and emotionally draining but at the end
of the day you are not connected to this
person in any sort of permanent way you
haven't said your wedding vows you don't
have any kids with them all you have
done is you're planning on eventually
saying your wedding vows the whole point
of this process beforehand is to figure
out if that's what you really want to do
and if you're really ready to do that so
if you were writing to me and telling me
that your wife is controlling and you
have no freedom and you aren't happy and
it's not like it used to be and so on
and so forth then I would be
recommending various things you could do
to try to fix that fix your marriage put
yourself back on the right track put
yourself back into your proper place as
a man and not a child to be ordered
around and and that's what I would be
saying because if you're married then
you should fight for that marriage you
agreed to fight for it when you got
married but if you're not and you're
telling me that you're feeling that way
and you're telling me you're you're not
that happy and you don't feel respected
and you feel like you're being
controlled and you don't feel like she
listens to you and all of that then
there's a part of me that says why why
miserable why waste your time she
doesn't treat you well she doesn't
respect you why even bother trying to
fix it you don't have to that's the
thing when you're married you have an
obligation if there's an issue and there
are always be issues that come up you
have an obligation to try to fix it if
your
married you don't have that obligation
and so if you come up against something
and you say this you know what this is
just it's probably more trouble than
it's worth or if there's if there's an
issue with your you know girlfriend or
even fiance that appears to be so
fundamental and appears to lie at the
core of her being where you don't know
if it can be changed then again that
might be a reason to just go your
separate ways if you're not ready to do
that then I think at the very least you
say you've tried to talk to her I I
don't know if you've how direct you've
been in those conversations
I know oftentimes there are people who
say that they've tried to talk to their
significant other about this or that
issue but in reality they actually
haven't they've tiptoed around it and
then the moment they get any pushback
they go running for the hills I don't
know if that's the case for you if it is
the case then what I would say is have a
real conversation sitter now and look
her in the eye say to her I am not
feeling respect to this relationship I
am NOT happy you're trying to control me
you're trying to run my life I'm not
gonna put up with that okay that's not
the kind of relationship we're gonna
have I want this to work but I'm not
willing to be in a relationship where I
am not respected and where my happiness
is not taken into account at all so are
you willing to fix that or not and if
she says no or if she tries to flip it
around on you or if she tries to play
the victim or if she tries to make you
feel bad for bringing it up or if she
yells at you and she gets angry then I
would say that's it and they eat right
you know you tried but if she's not even
willing to listen to your perspective
and you haven't even got into the
marriage yet that's not a good foot to
start on and probably at that point I
would just I would just cut my losses
but maybe if this is the first direct
and frank conversation you've had maybe
maybe she didn't realize that you were
feeling this way and maybe she really
does try to fix it and maybe there is
something there worth salvaging
I don't know I tend to be skeptical
Nathan I got to be honest with you I
don't mean
to be a bummer but going into a marriage
and already feeling this way before you
even walk down the aisle it's one thing
look to feel nervous to be questioning
is this the right decision all of that
is normal but what you're saying is I
don't know if it's worth working out
she's controlling you don't feel
respected you don't have freedom I mean
those are those are the kinds of issues
that if they're gonna come up you know
maybe they come up 15 years into the
marriage and you hit a rough spot a
rocky patch and then and then you work
through it maybe you go to marriage
counseling but to be walking down the
aisle with that kind of baggage I would
recommend against it so one way or
another you don't want to walk down now
with that baggage and if that if you can
sort this out with her then great but
otherwise if you just have to end the
relationship then I would do that as
well
all right I think we'll just we'll leave
it there and thank you for watching
everybody thank you for listening
Godspeed
the bat wall show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]